[Music]
Las Vegas' could be the venue for Super
Bowl 58 How are you greeted by Cristian
Cásseres with his brief
News Now report in Spanish Las
Vegas videos announced this at a
press conference on Wednesday inside the
stadium to the linesman the owners  the nfl
will say it officially and
the 2024 superbowl will be here in las
vegas this would be the first in the city
and I tell you that the pharmaceutical company fire
assures that the
antivirus treatment pill could be
available to the general public
very soon  the company's seal says
that this pill is almost 90 percent
effective in reducing the risk of
contracting the coronavirus of ending up
hospitalized or even dying from the
virus also that it will work in adults
without vaccination but must be taken within
three days of showing symptoms  Results
from laboratories show that this
also works in the face of the unique variant.
Two sisters from the valley are already
calmer after r  recover their mobile
food stand, the same one that
had been stolen less than a week ago,
carla and ailín enríquez say they are very
happy after a
news neon viewer recognized soccer, this
was parked in the apartment complex
where the
viewer resides and quickly  They
contacted the authorities and after the
storm they say that calm is coming but
in this case it is the cold I observed how the
low temperatures will continue for
the next few days after the storm
on Tuesday we will have a sunny day
however it will feel very cold
we will have  of digits in the 50 degrees
for the maximum and they will go down at night I am
Cristian Cáceres with his cold informative
of ignis nao in Spanish good day